[Music]
double is the best role with the worst
players period in a discussion
they are the ugliest players they have
the hardest social anxiety they're
delusional and their parents don't love
it true extreme is Monday I'm not sure
what time it is going to be a unranked
to challenger jumble only the jungle
unranked challenger it is time to
[ __ ] prove to these little jungle ass
[ __ ] how easy their goddamn role is
the role is easy and I am here to prove
it he's literally gonna have a negative
win rate Oh [ __ ] diamonds [ __ ]
juggle delusional [ __ ] mates how
[ __ ] easy that roll is
[ __ ] my [ __ ] nope still [ __ ] dead
don't go damn fire me god damn Grand
Master
juggle here instead me I I'm about to
Yelp my quantum you me you know Tyler
one he's the formerly ultra toxic
energetic Draven main who dominates
twitch so like toddler was talking loud
mom I wish I could run that fast like
jab
we don't give a [ __ ] you can't run
without legs keep [ __ ] talk in a
gravity these days he streams to tens of
thousands of people and though he's
changed a lot he's remained loyal to
Draven
but this year
Tyler needed to put Draven on the back
burner in fact he needed a break from
the whole bot lane that's my last time
playing 80 carry for like a month so
whatever I don't want to deal with that
[ __ ]
I hope and I hope by that time we come
back to ad carry motley it's [ __ ] to
fix but that's not gonna [ __ ] happen
see according to Tyler there's one group
of players in particular who for far too
long have whined about how tough they've
had it how they've had to survive patch
after patch and deal with dozens of
brain-dead teammates [ __ ] juggle
delusional [ __ ] mates how [ __ ]
easy their role is and what better way
to put junglers in their place than by
becoming a high rank jungler himself
Tyler decided once and for all to prove
how easy and overpowered the jungle
actually is after I get [ __ ]
challenger I don't want it I don't want
to see another tumblr or my Twitter
timeline I don't want to click a stream
and here another juggler ever say I roll
so bad this is Tyler one we're talking
about of course he's gonna be cocky and
talk [ __ ] when it comes to taking on
this challenge you can give your
teammates food but you can't make em eat
it I'm pretty soon we've got some pretty
spread so I'll [ __ ] shut that [ __ ]
down the throat I guess we'll see on
your honour iike challenger a yes but he
quickly got humbled must of the surprise
of no one oh absolutely
[Music]
who
hello flash ignite
[Music]
[Music]
game-by-game though he got better
[Music]
that ayah
i smite it early again this is what
you're gonna be [ __ ] kiddin Susan
[ __ ] challengers this is the state of
play right here watchin it paint enjoy
the [ __ ] show chat enjoy it
[Music]
let's go let's go I'm in today then what
other [ __ ] kid's gonna say
I love you Katerina I love you I love
you I love you I love you fro let's go
just like that what I [ __ ] say I said
I'm going to Game five my what
or the [ __ ] content and what's [ __ ]
better than an action-packed thriller
back and forth open Nexus Oh
the odds are down you think t1 is gonna
lose but t1 never [ __ ] lose and the
[ __ ] it done he got in Dimond now his
goal was proving everyone wrong and
getting masters you know dude I'll make
a bet with Tyler I'll make a bet if he
thinks he's so much better than me and
you guys think you so much better than
me clip in check that alright I wanted
oh I'll make a bet I'll make them pay I
will get challenger before Tyler hits
masters accept it take it or leave it
for 500 subs
I told you and now it was time for the
jungle streamers to pay either with
their wallets or with their sanity
[Music]
Oh yikes
that's the steam Oh what the soloqueue
gods are fickle and soon after they
turned on alright so we're back to
diamond one this should not honestly
this should be better because we have to
try and fix our MMR but I don't know did
so will Tyler whine complete his quest
and make it to Challenger who knows and
honestly does it even matter the
challenge has been hilarious from the
fails to the winds we've all had a blast
watching I'll tell you this juggles the
easiest role in the game and it's not
even close
all these jugglers you see they say oh
sorry I know there's a struggle for you
learns that say that it's hard and all
my laners they're bad thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]